let's talk about this new remix that you
announced with demi lovato
i'm so excited because both of you guys
have these
amazing powerhouse voices
how did the the collaboration come about
even
she is so supportive and so so sweet and
actually
her and sam smith um were talking about
how much they love
my new album because they put out a song
together and they did like this joint
interview
and i i texted her i'm like girl thank
you so much for
you know for listening and showing love
and we started going back and forth i
think she told me that lonely hearts was
one of her favorites and i was like
why don't you get on it and she was like
okay so really it was like that
and we were able to make it happen um
even though we recorded it in separate
places and
she absolutely destroyed it she killed
it i i texted her after i'm like what is
your range where are you singing from
like your where is this coming from it's
just amazing i'm
so excited that she took the song
and elevated it and uh i can tell that
we can both relate to the lyrics and
we've both been there before so and and
for me it's very applicable right now
just feeling like you know what
i'm i'm good at being alone and i i
don't want to be heartbroken and
if i'm alone i know i can't get
[Music]
heartbroken
how long have you and demi known each
other for i mean you said that you
texted her so i assume this friendship
goes way back again we've known each
other for such
such a long time it's funny because i
came out
i put out my first album when i was 13
so a lot of people think i'm much older
than i am but
i think i'm just a year older than her
so it's funny that she
she grew up listening to me and and has
always been
so sweet and always told me that we have
known each other for a long time and
i have a lot of respect for her yeah i
love hearing stories just about like
women supporting women
yeah i think i think we both feel a
connection with each other what do you
think she adds
to the track that does really elevate it
like is there something special that you
can kind of hint at or tease
yeah i i went back in and did new
ad-libs actually
because i wanted this to be special and
not just like we flew in her verse like
we're really going back and forth this
is a true duet so
that's really exciting because it feels
much more like a duet than a feature
where as you just kind of copy and paste
something in like we're really
um complimenting each other and and i
think that's really
nice to hear especially from to women
voices
and and to people who are spoken about
for their voices
there's no competition on this record
she
is completely in her own lane i'm
completely in my own lane
and it's just it's um
it's fire you just gotta hear it you're
using your platform for good which i
love that you're doing you're performing
as part of a virtual festival benefiting
my friend's place
so kind of talk to me about what that is
and why that was
important for you to to be part of
we both live in los angeles right you're
here so
as you know the issue of homelessness
is one of the the biggest that our
city faces and it's particularly
heartbreaking to see
young people experiencing it and i i
just know that
any one of us is just
one circumstance one degree away from
that being us
no one is is exempt from or better than
or smarter than like it that's not
what it is and the issue of homelessness
is truly life or death so my friend's
place
is making a serious difference here in
los angeles
with not only providing hope and
creative outlets
for these young people from ages of 12
to 25.
and but also actual
you know substantial health with with
housing
and food and education and child care
and job opportunities and and giving
them
giving them the tools to create their
own path forward which is just really
i just want to be a part of it can you
tease a little bit what you're going to
be performing
yeah um a couple of my favorite songs
from my new album
and yeah just sparing my soul like i
always try to do
the lineup is incredible though i mean
we have kenzie ziegler
chris paul's a part of this um anyone
that you're excited to
virtually check out i love chris paul
actually you know who i'm excited about
i think mario is performing it's just
funny because
i mean we kind of came up in the same
time like starting in the early 2000s
and he seems to be on like a path of
spirituality and transcendence so i'm
really excited to see
what his performance is about you have a
lot of exciting things
coming up so i want to get into you and
your music
what you need comes out friday
yeah yeah what should we know about this
song
it's the next level of confidence it's
basically like
i bring everything to the table i i am
100 i am complete
and if you don't see that then i can't
sit around and wait for you to see that
so you need to articulate what you need
from me if i'm not if it ain't it then i
got to go because i can't stay in this
no man's land forever like i'm just too
fly
so that's what it is when you are in a
relationship
what do you feel like you bring to the
table like what are
some of your good qualities you feel
like we always ask people like what are
you looking for in a person but i want
to know
that's a great way to put it because we
are much more in control of our fifty
percent that we bring to a relationship
you know what i mean
and um what i
can bring is a lot of passion
and presence and patience is something
i've developed over the past few years
i'm not a naturally patient person but
i've learned to be
and i'm actually i can be nurturing and
i can cook my ass off
you do bring so much to the table are
you dating at all in quarantine like how
is that
situation yeah i was in a bit of a
situationship
but it's
i'm single i'm single are you bummed
that it's over
yeah of course yeah it's acceptance is
really hard acceptance is hard when you
think
something's gonna be one way but
it's something i'm working on well i
also want to talk about you have been
posting these pictures
and a lot of them are because you're an
ambassador for rihanna's
savage line how did that come about did
she
reach out to you i heard people reached
out to me so
that savage reached out and
i guess i have a good rack and i guess
they wanted to see it in
there so uh i was like hey that sounds
great
i'm just at a place where i'm much more
comfortable with with my body
and um feel no shame in
in wearing whatever it is that i feel
like wearing so
lingerie has been something i've really
enjoyed for a long time like i
yes i like to dress up for if i'm in a
relationship but
even more so i really like to do it for
myself i just feel put together i feel
like
if i'm out in the world uh-huh i have a
little secret that you don't know
my last question is dancing on the stars
is coming back and i feel like you would
be
epic on that show have you ever thought
about or been approached
to do dancing with the stars i have been
approached yeah it's just not something
i'm interested in doing right now you're
not no you're focused on the music 100
[Music]
you